Як планували та здійснили зухвале вбивство
журналіста Павла Шеремета,Артем Шевченко
може розповісти в усіх подробицях.
Він очолює департамент комунікацій МВС України.
І з 7-ї години 45 хвилин ранку 20-го липня минулого року
змушений постійно звітувати пресі
про перебіг розслідування.
Ось ця, це камера,яка розташована на Мак Дональдсі,
вона чітко фіксує перехрестя
і вона зафіксувала чітко момент вибуху,
а також були вилучені камери спостереження
з усього району.
Мегабайти відеозаписів дали слідству багато інформації.
Вибухівку під машину Шеремета встановили в ніч перед убивством,
підірвали - дистанційно. Імовірно, звідси -
стоячи біля цього напівзруйнованого будинку.
Тут зручний паркан, за яким можна сховатися.
Вона ж була зафіксована ця особа, коли вона залишала
місце скоєння злочину.
Це ймовірна головна підозрювана – жінка.
Окуляри на все обличчя, мабуть перука, непримітний одяг.
Жодних особливих прикмет не має й її напарник–чоловік.
Хто ці люди, навіщо вони заклали вибухівку, це була їхня ініціатива,
чи вбивство хтось замовив -
питання, на які слідство і через рік
не знає відповіді.
Багато що з особистого і професійного життя Павла Шеремета
слідство досі не з'ясувало -
запити українських правоохоронців до Росії і Білорусі,
де журналіст мав багато контактів, так і залишилися
без відповідей.
І громадянство Павла Шеремета, і його контакти в РФ, поїздки в РФ,
і його контакти з втікачем -
високопоставленим колишнім міністром доходів і зборів Клименком
інші контакти
в середовищі рос опозиціонерів
дають нам підстави
з високим ступенем вірогідності вважати,
що російський слід доволі реальний
у вбивстві Павла Шеремета.
На думку Шевченка, ще переконливішою
ця версія стає на тлі інших чотирьох убивств,
які відбулися упродовж року після загибелі Шеремета.
Четверо офіцерів СБУ і Міноборони,
повязаних з контррозвідкою, загинули схожим чином –
їхні автівки також підірвали.
Це говорить про те, що в країні, якщо хочете, діє
така доволі професійна
високо законспірована мережа,
яка використовує спосіб
підриву транспортних засобів
ліквідацій, якщо хочете, вбивств на замовлення і терактів,
то це факт.
Вбивства контррозвідників досі не розкриті,
ці справи веде СБУ. Вбивство Шеремета, яким займається
Головне слідче управління Нацполіції, теж. Пишатися нічим -
визнає Шевченко. Але, додає,
одного дня він таки зможе повідомити
українському суспільству про успішне розкриття
вбивства Павла Шеремета.